Here I'm back to tell you how to write conditions in Java. Those conditions
that you can put inside an if statement to make a decision. Often times you
want to compare two values to see which one is smaller, which one is larger and
there are a bunch of operators that you can use. Here's a list of them. A
couple of them look just like what they look in regular mathematics. The others
look slightly different. This one here, you would write as greater than or
equal, or maybe greater than or equal, like that, in math. This one here is a
less than or equal. This one here is a simple equality, and this one here is a
not equal. Of course, these three symbols were chosen because there's no
keyboard character , for the mathematical symbols. The equal, equal on the
other hand was chosen because the plain old equal already has another meaning.
In Java you use the equal, equal for comparison and the single equal sign for
assignment. If you want to assign a value to a variable, here we want to assign
the number 13 to the variable 4. Then we use the equal sign, and of course
afterwards, floor is 13. If on the other hand, we want to test whether or not
floor equals 13, then we use the equal, equal comparison symbol. Let's put if
statements and relational operators to use in a fun graphical way, to draw
flags. Here you see the flag of Indonesia, as simple as flags get, red on top,
white on the bottom. Here you see the outline of a simple class for drawing a
flag. Its get color at method, its called for every x and y value in the flag,
your job will be to complete it so that the correct colors appear. You'll
want to know the dimensions of the flag, so that you can decide when to use red
and when to use white. And they're available to you in these instance
variables. Don't worry about how the get color at method is, called. You can
actually peek below and see it, but it uses loops, which we only introduce in
the next lesson. Right now your job , is to fill out this method here. Put in a
condition here, select the right colors. And as an added challenge, I want you
to use the greater or equal operator. Now be careful, for exactly half of the
rows, you want red, and for exactly half of the rows, you want white.